and welcome to punch-drunk sports where
winners win win and never stop winning
god damn if you're watching on youtube
you knows how good I look right now I
woke up like this
I think that's not and just [ __ ] cape
we got a packed house guys
no re today it's a to freeze oh oh
joining me as always uh just the love of
my life the light in my life my good
friend Jason Tebow hi everybody
fight nannies here Johnny's on the one
and two Erin's over there crying cuz
Dodgers are in the train on his [ __ ]
st. Louis Cardinals and in-studio are
very excited to have him a good friend
of mine I've known him for many many
years going on two decades he's got a
wonderful YouTube channel to tell us
about our good friend the party starter
darren carter hey everybody thanks for
having me darren carter the party
starter how are you dan what is your on
YouTube YouTube is might the darren
carter channel and my podcast is called
pocket party and what do you do on i
just yeah it's a little bit inspiration
motivation humor and interview people
have people on great conversations and I
like people to walk walk away learning
something and Phil enlightened that's
great yeah you know what I mean it's a
lot like lunch doing so real quick we
have a we're going to do some dates out
of the gates I wanted to start off with
one is we're very excited to announce
that the next big UFC fight was it UFC
UFC whatever is the economy really
that none of us know yeah Konica b5 2229
I think 829 feel like it's either you
hate him when you love him and yeah
really
UFC 229 what's the date on that October
6 mm u FC 229 Sun Strunk will be live at
the sycamore Tavern upstairs at dojo
we're gonna be doing our play-by-play
Jason myself we're gonna have our friend
Matt Slayer there Johnny will be there
fight nany if she can [ __ ] stop
putting out kids she'll come and hang
out but I don't want to you know you're
not gonna even come for a major event
that's how much I don't want to support
I said it wasn't gonna watch it I could
come and leave before okay how about you
just sit in the other room on hallway
just for the head but we're gonna be
doing a live event there followed by
stand-up comedy yes you like to karate
hottie though yeah you love that karate
hottie so if she wins and it's a good
fight dude I think that's a good card
I'm a that kid O'Malley Zhanna he's fun
to watch
O'Malley's fun to what not that guy dude
both of those guys are good to walk both
pedis brothers are fighting yeah you
love those Pettis bro I remember when
Sergio lost once Anthony said he
wouldn't fight with him on the same
cardigan because he thinks that's why he
lost because it was too hard yeah now
they [ __ ] he's like [ __ ] I got I just
got a fight I mean Paris has never been
the same since the know since the PD I
have my Wheaties box on a frame still
you know hoping he's gonna get it back
together
so guys Jason were you gonna be I'm
gonna be at the UFC 229 you have
what is it - 29 - 29 and our big UFC
[Laughter]
fight companion I will be at the Venice
underground ox - a few days after that
October 10th they'll be at the Venice
underground and of course I'll be just
like the rest of us at the big all
things comedy festival October 26 7th
and 8th I believe is when that will be
so come see us that weekend and then I
will be sucking dick behind a dumpster
at the big you are you gonna get a
babysitter for that baby Darren Carter
the party starter where are you gonna be
yes October 4th check me out and if
you're in solving the solving area
October 4th I'll be at Veterans Memorial
Hall and I'll be in Reno in November if
my hometown is Fresno and the day after
Thanksgiving that Friday and Saturday
I'll be at decicco's and it's a great
it's a famous Italian restaurant that
area did Chico's November I want to say
23rd and 24th but otherwise go to the
pocket party podcast I mentioned the
dates like you said dates out the gates
at the beginning of every show perfect
guys
tonight I'm at the dojo of comedy is
should go out tonight
October ok following week I have comedy
chaos live at The Comedy Store right now
we have feel vom Whitney Cummings and
Bert Kreischer so grab those tickets
more to be announced and then October
3rd I am la la
ah I will be live at the filly no I'll
be in live at the Brea improv would say
an evening of Sam Tripoli and his weirdo
friends
we got the smash brothers Corrine Chad
George Perez Kate Quigley just got added
and Mike Tully so go check that out and
then ah the 12th
it's the tinfoil hat comedy night at the
Philly punchline that's right Philly
punchline Eddie Bravo myself gonna be at
the Philly punch I go to Philly punch
Lang calm and then I'm also us going
back to the 607 and the three one five
we're gonna be at the I will be the
tinfoil hat we'll be at the Syracuse
funny bone in the Destiny mall the mall
named after a black stripper that will
be head go grab your tickets at Syracuse
funny bone calm and support the live
shows will be coming around and yeah
that was it dude and it a lot of great
[ __ ] going on dude a lot of great [ __ ]
we are now entering my favorite time of
the year it's either this or like late
March but this is my favorite because
all the spar sports are starting to rock
yep and it's so much great [ __ ]
football's in big swing now now that
we're slowly starting to see who's who
who were the pretenders who are
potential contenders are you worried
about your Raiders no because we are
first-half champs we're mod duh feed it
in the first half no one's beating us in
the first half we've won every first
half that we have played so I am happy I
had to find them hurtin believe I'm so
like the glass half for ya so we're
doing fine we're doing fine I don't know
why we play second half it's a row
they're losing yeah baby I love your
positive yet to win a game we're like I
don't know football but I'm like I think
I yeah so it's pretty cool to be like
that guy that walked up what do you do
he walked off the field and retired
half time yeah that's the greatest
retirement yeah they were losing and
he's not a young guy Johnny hold on what
do you have up there I saw you have
something oh is that the punching sports
fantasy football because you saw a
finger monsters yeah I'm up I may not
win a game go up yeah I'm the finger
blasters but let's talk no don't click
that go down whose ass I want to look at
something we're doing [ __ ] on the
line up where they ranked sex and worse
where's Falcon holics oh I won't win it
I might not win a game in this why my
team's garbage in this ha ha ha why did
we go 14 people in this league because
we invited 11 people on the hour before
the draft started normal like 12
yeah obably most most people do Ted they
they enjoy tad 12 is the most common but
Tebow likes 12 and for some reason
Johnny got excited when support team I
don't mind 14 I need I need Ingram based
on your rancor do you do based on my
record you're right
I need Ingram to get back back from
breaking yeah he's right to here and
then he just he does crawl work on the
defense as he goes he does that he's
look at this guy right here you're
probably Trumper that was my that's my
Rick Ingram
do you have any football team are you
into any drams your Rams but nice Bishop
back into it's hard to give me the Rams
I mean not really
you're there great well sir I'm saying
it should save my household because when
they came back to LA I'm like I'm
getting new jersey the Sox I'm gonna be
like you guys I'm gonna be a football I
get this song I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
do it and then I started like no I
didn't realize like I'm more of an
active person it's hard for me to sit
still for like I found that I would
fast-forward to do you know and then I
fast-forward to the boring parts and
then I was like I'm pretty much
fast-forwarding I mean you know no
offense anybody but I get it though
people who want to just get a pizza
chill and I didn't really have you don't
I mean like my wife isn't into of my
son's on into it and it's like I don't
where I was just like guys we're gonna
get in the football what are you guys
just smoke hookah and hang out with
Daniel yeah I know yeah my wife is like
we're gonna go to the track and run
around or go to Griffith Park and
exercise and I'm like okay that sounds
like fun
you know I'm gonna put my RAM socks on
in order to get back into the Rams this
year that I'm gonna do it again well
there's a year to do it this year there
- no right no they're just in yes saying
yes they're winning the important one
whole entire game ah I could see a Rams
versus Kansas City Superbowl kin cities
pretty damn tough there I mean just I
mean that guy is just throwing the ball
around do you think Jason as our
resident NFL expert do you believe that
maybe the rules are too slanted towards
the offense right now like like people
are putting up insane numbers like we've
never seen before like this year the QB
rating this last weekend the average QB
rating of the NFL is was higher than
Aaron Rodgers lifetime QB rating I mean
that's it that's a like inflated mean to
compare two games over somebody's entire
careers well I'm just saying no the
entire NFL meaning every game right the
QB rating it was higher than what one of
the greatest quarterbacks ever played
the game
his life his career rating do you know
yeah yeah but I'm saying like in two
games versus his entire career you know
your numbers are gonna go down that'll
that'll come down
that'll come back down but yeah they
make it hard for defenses I mean we had
two ties to tie in back-to-back weeks
it's a I think it's not even so much
like it's slanted towards the offense or
skewed rules it's they're doing so much
to stop Ct ease and head [ __ ]
collisions and like no any returns kicks
anymore I bet we won't see three maybe
five special team touch that or
punch like kickoff returns because no
nobody that kid they don't want that
anymore I think it's sad but things like
that are gonna lead towards ties because
they're little eliminating a lot of ways
where you can score but yeah man my
homes is legitimate
we knew that last year you know when he
was sitting on the bench you knew this
kid could throw the ball 70 yards on the
run but he has so many [ __ ] weapons
dude that team is built to score if they
had like a defense like the Rams or
Chicago or one of these defenses just
lights-out Chiefs would be through
booking they would be through booking
but uh I could see she's booking yep
Chiefs does that mean done it it'd be a
rather be over you've never heard that I
have you heard of that Johnny through
booking Aaron have you ever heard
through bucket
Jason if they had a defense man maybe a
turducken turducken they would be a
turducken through book and I'm gonna
start using that feel free through the
book it means done through booking how's
it smelled ex it spelled out you have
[Music]
Johnny what happened to the god Panthers
they really [ __ ] the bed this week huh
anyway won the first half and that's
what what we've learned today is all
that matters the first half is where the
real team comes out no I mean the
Panthers have one more win than the
Raiders yeah okay okay yeah yeah but we
are lost by a point so you know you guys
are sitting around here acting like we
should suck it we lost my [ __ ] point
and we missed two [ __ ] extra points
so what the [ __ ] do you want
I can't believe that you with all that
money that you'd saved by cutting or
just trading khalil Mac that you just
let janakowski go and then you knew
kicker misses two extra points yeah you
know he hit up 56 yarder yesterday for
Seattle by the way he couldn't look
fatter
I love it he looks like a 1940's
football player now I'm a weird guy
everything except for UFC I love fat
athlete UFC I can't stand bitched it it
drives me [ __ ] look at this guy what
of that
that's a kid we need them back that's a
kick they need to call him back he had a
56-yard yesterday on Monday Night
Football and with that kick became the
all-time leader in NFL history of
50-plus field goals 50-yard he's a
hall-of-famer oh definitely I mean they
play that long with one team do you
here's my prediction Pete Carroll leaves
after this year goes to USC
you heard it here you heard it [ __ ]
here
I don't USC not you oh yeah I I'm
willing to bet that he will not go to us
why do you think that other than that
used to be his job and they're not doing
well you'll see he's got I mean like the
they say the chemistry [ __ ] in Seattle
because he kiss Russell Russell Wilson's
ass and I think it's just there on that
back end of the economics of football
now where it's like you know you have
this five year window to build a
franchise and then one simply I mean
watch our whole defense gonna have two
three guys left from the legion of boom
or whatever they called it yeah there's
only two or three of those guys left
like they you know by the way how many
of those guys got busted for steroids
how the Legion of boom I don't know you
know I don't think any I can't somebody
talking about yesterday on the radio
that like half of them got busted for
please
I don't recall stray abuse fight leaves
you mean nuts see here host at bill burr
yeah I don't know I don't mean nothing
huge oh yeah bill burr was the one that
said that on the show he's a god half
those guys got busts for peds I'm on
fire my impressions today
I should do impression you should you
should you really should you actually
just do a tour of us oh that would be
really by the comics AHA which was that
that was a Bilborough oh it's pretty
good give us a little Patrice Patrice
O'Neal yeah what people don't [ __ ]
around white people about Katt Williams
get some Katt Williams I imagine that
was also my Chris Tucker though his Dave
Chappelle yeah Chris Tucker would be a
higher pitch and Dave Chappelle be lower
and slower harriet tubman I'm noticing a
pattern
Carrie telling you sways nobody know
about LeBron James
welcome to the Ku Klux Klan podcast he
just slowly hey we are we are in a nice
streak on the show by the way two weeks
in a row bald-headed redheads have been
on the show two weeks in a row
Darren Carter Oh following bill burr
boom what a great show man gee they had
a darren carter a bill bravo that would
be a $50 tour on that be awesome yeah I
would like that what he said I got go
first I agree too quick I agree too I'm
like that'd be awesome
yeah no you killed you did my Armenian
benefit show and like you went on last
and crotch great so I put the hat back
on now we get the idea we've lost a
couple viewers yeah yeah they might they
might think it's bill burr for a quick
second they are Jeff Ross yeah what
Johnny there's a guy on the Seahawks
named Barkevious Mingo you know you
remember that used to be jokes of black
people name their kids such crazy and
then you just see what white people are
doing now it's it's like stripper names
just the ones you can hang your kid
[ __ ] chakra or so that's a party vyas
Mingo impression I got here the balls in
there there we go what do you guys think
of that one the head girls right now all
did that there's Charlie Shiloh and Max
so I'm not the only one androgynous
people running around that's how you
know that comedy is not gonna is back
everybody having children now everyone
is having children now and the parking
lot looks like a Porsche dealership
Brogan was saying that look at these all
these cars I'm like yeah they're
everybody who does your show yeah yeah
everybody does Rogan show has a [ __ ]
brand-new golf course you get a Porsche
yeah Roku Wow the parking lot used to be
like a rowboat and just Scott's car when
it was new
a phat James just like demolition derby
everybody's car yeah you know I mean
dude that the everything was sold out
last thing it was what was it like or no
only Sunday night it was yeah sold out
yeah crazy right
on a Sunday six sold-out shows so well I
you think I'll be driving a Porsche
after this appearance yeah seeing a
Porsche driving by as you wait for
triple-a to fix your car yeah we're up
there with them it's like Grogan and us
and the biggest podcasts out there I
think I need to hear an impression Robin
Williams get about beat up dupe top no
way
what if Robin Williams is black black
people be driving like this
do you guys hear Katt Williams going
after Tiffany Haddish yeah sad yeah
why it just makes me sad because like
it's what do you mean romance going
happy people have to go after you what
do you mean go after like what it's like
oh he ain't she ain't going um
oh they squash beef good good and I love
you know I love both of them and I do I
love my huge Katt Williams fan I was
really funny and I did i man when you I
watch the whole interview he's really
good you know he's like kissing her ass
yeah you should dude that girl's a great
story man I know and yeah and stop
wearing two racks you're at the Emmys
sir I this is not a do-rag sir yeah dude
finally a good one that was good that
was a great impression mr. Tripoli he's
always really nice you know whose cousin
is right mm-hmm
ah Ludacris Oh cuz I remember back in
the day when I used to do chocolate
sundaes I annihilated with your
impressions of him who's my impressions
of all the comics before me there's my
impressions of everybody in the audience
I'll be in the audience right now that's
a funny voice thanks that could just be
your voice do your act in that boy I
know when you're sick jokes in that
voice let me hear why people be driving
like this but black people be driving
like that dude you might be on some time
I am I am grieved that Johnny that was
uncalled for her I should not be on the
podcast awful it's good thank you all
god you're making Darren uncomfortable
look at him he can't even look into the
camera
take it off I can't believe that so was
a real thing I can't believe I fell out
yeah it's so bad do this yeah do the
voice but don't do that don't go with
the makeup I wouldn't I'd leave that off
this is that's right you probably
shouldn't do that they might just think
you could be like a redneck you know you
just be saying it's a redneck character
is this an offensive joke I was talking
about how like the most racist person on
the in the
world is the white chick Oh only bangs
black guys like you ever know they will
only bang black guys and I find that so
racist yeah the race against white guy
so I tell this girls like come on she's
like I'm in the black I go I'll pay my
dick black face how about that one
how'd that go over she laughed that's
good yeah I mean it still didn't get it
I'll pay my take black fee the
Kardashians dude when will this end when
will this end
never I know you did this to your South
America you did this to yourself you do
this to you
you made them famous that's kind of
weird to it cuz you know your Armenian
like so now before your what we know
over yeah cuz we did you try to you try
to explain what's Armenian and then you
and then now the Kardashians yes yeah I
go [ __ ] yeah back in the day back in the
day was there like a racism thing where
people do like Armenian face that is
offensive against fire I guess that is
offensive [ __ ] fire double album the
first one sides black it's just the same
plasm yeah the same jokes so I decide
something on my special I'm putting it
out myself and I'm getting all the one
you shot at the Viper Room yeah I'm
breaking it up into halves as I like
both names you win the first half we
know that about you put it out both half
it up arm og Armageddon and zero I love
it
so I things can be out round but
whatever loves our mo get you my wife's
Armenian she'd love Armageddon yeah did
yeah I got put out cuz if I don't
somebody else will somebody else will
where did you buy your wife meat it's
gonna be called Viper Room live at the
Viper Room one live at the Viper Room to
live Viper one Armageddon live at the
Viper Room to zero [ __ ] cuz I can't put
0 Fox it won't get on I - yeah or any
that other
stop so I have to get creative you have
to kind of give a [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I
have to go far if you call it that what
do you mean you can't put in our iTunes
won't let it won't put up you know when
when Eddie IFFT had talking [ __ ] they
constantly took down his uh his podcast
because it said the word [ __ ] really
yeah that's the title said [ __ ] so you
call it talking hits or something like
that like yeah talking's hit yeah that's
called that's crazy yeah welcome to
crazy it'll say zero [ __ ] or it won't
say it they will say well it's just it's
gonna say it when the video runs oh but
not in a title oh okay
on iTunes yeah and that's yeah
everywhere else who will say it but
iTunes who will not can you put like a
like a symbol or something zero f you
know I'm not gonna even dance in it like
when I do you to my other podcast I
don't put any risky names in yeah cuz
they'll they'll [ __ ] D monetize it
mmm so I just said oh okay
I'm just gonna name the guy in the
briefest description right when you're
doing that that's why I do what I'm
gonna do with iTunes briefest
description no swear words no nothing
but I'm excited to put it out and I'm
excited that like you know I might I'm
getting I'm probably my next won't be a
half an hour I'm just gonna put out 1/2
hours when you say put it out what do
you were will it be put out like you
have you figured that out yet well I'm
gonna put it everywhere I'm gonna put it
on iTunes Amazon I'm gonna put it out on
YouTube you could do it on YouTube you
can now sell content on YouTube like
video yeah to be like $2 wonderful hmm
why not man yeah I mean like listen dude
you could go I've been on Comedy Central
granted one time 15 years ago but you
know I could be like oh my specials on
Comedy Central and nobody watch it
because they put it on like Saturday at
11:00 which is literally dead top they
like rerun them in the middle of the
night and then they don't think if they
run him at all yeah yeah that's right so
it's like why not just put out myself
and then later honestly like Maria
Bamford Sebastian Maniscalco Ari all
their first hours her specials were in
at specials what what what is something
grow it currently that people
religiously watch on Comedy Central
like what it what's there I can't think
Park I Nathan for you is pretty broad
city no nobody's watching broad city I
mean South Park I would Aaron does rest
is popular yeah but yes Queen
the popular miss of the show give me
numbers because I can't see numbers cuz
he fights with me on everything
who Aaron who know Johnny what are the
numbers of these shells what account
essential rain Nathan for use funny I
didn't even know it was how much I don't
know well that's the thing I don't know
yeah you know in it everybody just seeks
whatever content they want and watches
it whenever they want I don't know who's
like setting their DVR for I get I guess
I was a park for sure yeah yeah like I
just can watch these dramas that's all
dude you know what I watched the [ __ ]
Emmys last night rich kids getting
richer did did you watch it
no like I don't care what did Tiffany
won an Emmy for I don't know what she
wouldn't have guest hosting SNL dude
that's pretty that's a pretty man I
remember her hosting at the Long Beach
Laugh Factory where like three years ago
I remember doing like open mic a potluck
yeah I'm like thinking she was great
like yeah that was forever ago yeah oh
yeah she uh she was always like crazy
yeah yeah she would host a lot those are
the numbers YouTube streams okay go up
so that's three years ago do we have
anything from now oh I miss key and
Peele oh my god talk about to [ __ ]
careers gone different ways yeah one
guys doing life funny though is tossed
alone cop yeah that's funny that's funny
yeah he's funny one point two million
which is not a lot
I guess I guess there's all cuz you
didn't want to believe the people watch
abroad I still don't believe they watch
broad city I don't believe any [ __ ]
these numbers I don't hear nobody's
talking about broad city
I hear none of it I hear and I wish them
well nothing I hear people talking about
that show I've never watched it but I
mean why cause you're doing coke in the
women's bathroom no I mean three people
half the people in this room talk about
that show and say it's great I've
actually mostly heard men liking it
actually okay okay I guess I'm an
[ __ ] up debut okay I guess I'm wrong
yeah broad city you win
Sam blood should you want it on that
damn Triple E zero I don't want to I
enjoy talking about lizard people I know
talking about lizard people all right
that's what I'm into okay guys been a
great show Wow she's pretty hot right
there huh what is that where do you go
woman wearing that outfit you would be
in job let's feel any really feminine
guy wearing that I like that show I
would watch yeah that's broad city yeah
what is that about Yas Queen what is
that about [ __ ] guy who watch his
show oh that's what she says okay all
right that's how we do it did that's how
we [ __ ] do it big one of our bigger
fears came to fruition recently okay to
washboard and go into the Patriots
that's never been one of my fears and
that make total sense though for him to
go there show up after working out to go
see [ __ ] Hillary Clinton she's like
[ __ ] I'm at the gym could I still show
up should I still nope nobody thought
that ship like a hello my name is sue
Curt I don't even know the whole thing
sucks that whole group sucks it's an
episode where they're volunteering for
I'm not big Amy Poehler fan really why I
think she's hilarious
every hilarious if you go off on her and
then like next thing you know just like
with Katt Williams and Tiffany you're on
your knees like
thank you a big fan started the show
real positive he's jacked is he good he
just got let go of his team so he's a
mental case mmm he's a mental [ __ ]
case and hopefully they think they can
Corral him he can't stop smoking weed
right he's had his problem or he's just
mentally shish-kebab what do you do a
breakdown of trust between the Browns
and troubled receiver Josh Gordon
ultimately led to his departure Monday
after he allegedly misled the team and
sustained an injury while shooting a
commercial at the Ohio facility sources
- athletic oh like shooting a commercial
for something Oh
blew his hamstring out and they're like
[ __ ] dude we just got you back and now
you're doing this [ __ ] and it's a it was
an on team that amazing nature didn't
even know he was doing it so we got
injured shooting a commercial well yeah
they originally said was a photo shoot
yeah he told me was doing that didn't
know he was like exercising and doing
all kind of [ __ ] going all out like
you're about to finally get on the field
again you did play week one and then was
a healthy scratch week two and they're
like they were just like dude where you
really only make $700,000 a year I mean
that's a lot of money - he like owned so
many chances the Josh Gordon 34 30 will
be about eight hours long why did the
Patriots take him then he sounds like
because they he's phenomenal
but you always had trouble getting
suspended for drugs he's John Jones yeah
basically John Jones yeah well gunfight
nanny that's a yes can we when we do the
highlights of fight nanny Ken's have a
kid she brought the best point she's
ever brought up on this show look Google
me totally Google Image uh Gordon she
could see how Jack this guy is I mean
he's a physical specimen he's super
talented and when he's sick when he's
glad big dick
problems I mean that dude is straight up
jack that's a wide receiver bro that
dude is I feel like I'm looking at me
hey don't you have a great impression to
him
Oh throw me the ball mister remember run
some sprints
look at that dude so much I gotta be
honest with you the advancement in black
tattoos has gone so far I mean they used
to just you can see them yeah it's
amazing right yep your most racist
absolutely without question is so far
our most racist episodes
okay heard this this isn't my joke but I
heard this about that and they said this
guy goes tattoos on black people looks
like skywriting at night and I just that
image just stuck with me
look at that dude that's my favorite MMA
fighter [ __ ] tits McGee up oh who's
that [ __ ] tits go to [ __ ] tits
oh that looks like every MMA for a
heavyweight now nobody works out they
just come in with tits flapping did you
jump did anybody other than I know
Johnny did watch the triple G and a foul
Alvarez I did I later on he sent me the
link to it yeah he sent me the link to
it what did you think ah I think it was
a close fight what super close fight but
I I think triple G want it just like you
won the first one it just makes it
impossible to like Canelo it just makes
it impossible it's hard to to get popped
for performance-enhancing drugs whether
he was easy picking meat okay whatever
and then root for that person it really
is I mean I've always liked him but it's
hard for you you find yourself in like
cash it's like rooting against the Lance
Armstrong you're like okay sure you're
in the Tour de France again and
apparently a clean I just don't root for
that yeah and you know it's like mild
things like I think everybody's doing
some sort of juicing but I mean when you
when you put it into uh when he fought
Floyd Mayweather and he's so obviously
lost that fight and one of the judges
had it as a draw mm-hmm it's just like
it's not fun to walk
it's not fun the wall and then you got
Oscar De La Hoya putting out this
dumbass [ __ ] thing which states that
ah you know we should be celebrating
this I didn't pick the refs
everybody got to pick the [ __ ] judges
and all this [ __ ] and it's just like you
know dude it's just like nobody saw the
only people who saw Canelo win that
fight are the guys on HBO if you listen
to all the different like international
coverage of it
people had triple G up four rounds three
rounds Harold Lederman had him up like
winning by four or five rounds Johnny
sent me something for the first time
ever it was basically set where it's
like they were like the guys like I I
have triple G out for four rounds four
rounds and they're like well people
around the ring have it uh have it all
scored a different way I'm not I've
never heard that before that was a hard
fight too so I mean I could see that
going anyway if any of these two fights
were a draw it to me it was the second
one not the first one but it's like to
me you know we always say that on the
show to be the champ you got to beat the
champ that wasn't beating the champ you
know I mean you have to decisively
especially a guy who's in his entire
career
he's like 39 and oh never been beat to
me I just don't think he beat him I'd
like to see round 25 I mean I'd like to
see these guys fight again you know
they're gonna fight again but the
problem is is that that Agalloch ins
getting older and older yeah yeah
[ __ ] sucks
it's like 27 and 36 or something was
there's like a 10 year age difference
right so if they fight they fight again
it has to be soon you can't give two
years before they fight again I would
too if I was him fast can allow it to
it's a great fight man I was talking to
you I mean like I feel Canelo if he
would have lost that fighting the judges
and it was this close he would walk down
there were way more credit he's getting
right now in the wind that people don't
feel e1 and like you talked a lot
boxing enthusiast is like it's not a
robbery but I did have them winning
that's what the feeling is it's not a
robbery and the first one everybody
thought the draw was a robbery this one
they're like triple G one but it was a
close fight yeah that's I mean that's
how I pretty much would have had its
core the exact same way just flip
I had triple G vie about two or maybe
even three rounds you know what it was
is that they gave they gave Canelo the
last round where Canelo got rocked by
two big hits by uh triple T and there's
no way Canelo won that last round
there's no [ __ ] way I agree there's
about three rounds where I think triple
G decisively won the round and 12 was
one of those rounds that's what caused
the fight I was talking to Morgan Murphy
about it she's a big boxing I love
Morgan Murphy there's nobody I love more
than Morgan Murphy and she was um sent
my mom she said that uh she put up very
in an interesting way where she's like
boxing is two different things
there's the actual boxing contest for
people box and then it's just like a
crapshoot of like okay well I know what
I think about the fight now let's see
what mystery [ __ ] political crazy
[ __ ] is about to happen so - the judges
gave the final round to canal oh yeah
that's what we just said it's just
ridiculous it's just ridiculous
if they scored it the other way it would
have been a draw across the board well
that's the problem is that day I think
that I don't know if the fix was in per
se boxing is always just a crapshoot
when it goes to the judges if you don't
knock somebody out
then you know hey that's what I say
don't leave it in the hands of the
judges but I think the fix was
absolutely in before this fight started
where they're like we just do not want
another draw whatever happens judges and
score this however you think you should
score it wink wink
not a draw again this can't be a jogging
right and if they would have scored that
last round honestly it's a draw
yeah it's I think that judges were
perhaps told not a job it's court
however you want to score it just don't
let it be a draw and as this fight is as
close as it is and if it's a draw it's a
draw in fairness I thought that was the
last straw I made money off that I only
have four dollars in my team bet D s I
bet the acai for all your bet needs go
to Betty aside calm use the promo code
punch 25 if you deposit money you'll get
20 but what do you get you get $20 or no
no that's the other one you get whatever
you deposit they will get they will
match it dollar for dollar up to $500
bet the S I bet these are our
longest-running sponsors our good
friends they are in it to win it so what
do you do you get like $20 0.5 25 $25
bedding cash yeah so I use Betty aside
to Betty I only have $4 left in my
account so I just put it on a draw and
it came out draw everybody's like the do
win a thousand dollars on there
no I only one like a hundred Oh what do
you put ball my on well I'm like I
couldn't I couldn't put the money in
quick enough before the fight so it was
at your Obama impression so yeah I mean
like I and I feel like these fights and
then this dumbass Mayweather versus
Pacquiao fight oh yeah I don't give a
[ __ ] about that
if I did it ten years ago ten years ago
I'd been excited to hear that
hey Mayweather it's finally not ducking
this guy yeah I I mean like I'm not
gonna watch the fight I'm not gonna
watch it even if it's free I won't watch
that fight I'm just tired of it and the
thing that sucks is boxing has done so
many has put on such great fights lately
[ __ ] like this is like this is the old
guard yeah he says Mayweather this is
Oscar De La Hoya who's like two out my
friend Darrell was telling me he's like
Oscar used to fight everybody he would
literally fight anything
and now as a promoter he's just [ __ ]
doing dog ship maneuvers putting out
this thing about can you look up like
his response to the whole fight and then
we can get dere and do it in that
awesome voice eh maybe do you have any
uh are you looking forward to the
Deontay Wilder Tyson Fury fake oh yeah
me too me I think oh yes yes I think
it's gonna be a great fight where is it
today I'd like to see fury gated [ __ ] a
little bit block knocked off Dooley
really the Oscar De La Hoya's voice
which is slightly feminine since he
likes to dress and drag and do coke okay
what am I reading who doesn't do you
fight fan we don't sort of a Mike Tyson
yeah okay well or Hispanic they're five
fans on the night of Saturday September
15th fans were said to be treated to
what sport should be allowed the two
best athletes in a sports growing off
against each other with the winner
earning the title of the best in the
business this kind of an event where an
individual can be called in to the best
in any sport is truly rare not only did
the fight yourself deliver all that was
promised against all kinds of pressure
another hour is give the performance of
his lifetime to secure the unified
middleweight championship of the world
hold on one second ah go down a little
bit jump to the jump go down go down go
down to is he answers all the points and
we'll get to it so you don't three out
keep going down keep going down here we
go
just read these couple okay okay so let
me tell you okay so Golden Boy paint
their judges to fix a fight okay okay
look okay though I don't think this
deserves response okay here are the
facts all right the three judges were
chosen by the Nevada State Athletic
Commission okay given the result of the
first fight in C a SC was under a lot of
scrutiny to come up with the ferris
group of judges possible for the first
time I know of Golden Boy Promotions and
team triple G were even allowed to
approve of a pool of judges they saw
what everyone else did it gross
competitive fight and just courted
exactly that way okay all right all
right golovkin landing more punches and
therefore should have won
fight okay I hear you okay let me let me
tell you okay
if landing punches were the difference
between winning or lose it all down my
pants are getting tight or losing a
boxing match we would have an incredibly
different and less interesting sport all
right clean punching ring generalship
effective aggressiveness and defense are
what the judges are looking for okay
okay obviously a promoter all right but
in the four areas actually counting
judging I can't find limit okay so Tom
okay his statement that he doesn't know
if golovkin can win a decision in Las
Vegas okay perhaps tom is just looking
to make triple G feel better okay but
regardless this is this okay maybe it's
the most disappointing comment because
it comes from someone who knows the
sport all right of course triple G can
win a decision in Las Vegas but 22,000
people are going to crowd into the
t-mobile Arena to watch golovkin fight
and blast out the likes of Dominic Wade
Willie Monroe jr. or Vance
yeah Martirosyan the Armenian guy okay
he is going to need to fight a higher
level of competition and then fight
better than that of the opponent to earn
a victory in the mecca boxing boxing is
a wonderful sport that is coming back
thanks to streaming technology growing
international interests and Golden Boy
Promotions etc but it is a sport that
also faces competition not only from the
outside in the form of other more widely
watched leagues but from inside with a
fractured nature of boxing has made it
tougher and tougher for the best to face
ah alright [ __ ] the rest of that [ __ ]
he's just talking out his [ __ ] Darren
Carter with amazing cold-read Wow you
nailed that [ __ ] I got into it you
really did you're you're all you should
do some voiceover like I gave me some
direction yes you go these things that
go in an audition for a commercial and
they tell you what to do and then you
she has commercial and it's nothing of
what they told you to do I know to like
act like that and it's the exact
opposite
yeah it's [ __ ] not you nailed it you
should get a voiceover agent that's
right I'm gonna take off my hat so they
can recognize me there you go this guy
he hired this guy um you know the kind
of head that looks like you would get a
sunburn from that one I know that's why
we're in this pattern it sucks man look
at this when I get from the TV I'm like
you look like Jeff Bezos that's how you
look like like you just you run Amazon
and you're just gonna own the world I
don't you know when you have a face this
way maybe I should put on reading
glasses or something just so I can kind
of like have a look or something yeah
you dude you look like listen dude I rub
your project okay you look like you look
like a guy who wants to work with a
rapper to endorse like your new bottled
water right we have bottled water yeah
yeah you look like you beat cancer five
years ago yeah so you work out all the
time you do the workouts you like to
actually though I could see better with
these are of course they're called class
I do work out all the time you know what
it is it's I it's uh I well number one I
I go to the spot once I found boxing
boxing songwriting is the best it's like
you sweat completely I mean I but you
don't watch boxing though I like to do
it you don't like to watch it cuz you
can't because it's final and I'm just
kidding no I do watch boxing I watch box
it's funny man like late at night like
all uh I just learned to break this
habit I was training during the day and
then at night after you do your show for
me to relax I was going on YouTube and
watching boxing but while eating peanut
butter and crackers and I feel like like
a dumb [ __ ] just yeah I was like [ __ ]
man but so now at night I'm trying on
that to eat while I'm watching stuff but
yeah but you have been hitting the
boxing gym I usually go like three or
four times a week and those are big
rabbit holes in YouTube like yeah bully
gets what's coming to him or waiters
knockouts of all time
next you're like oh I'll watch this one
video it's like 2 hours later and I
I haven't blinked and so long one here
goes down my eye
trucker fights thugs or whatever yeah
yeah yeah and then I like the jujitsu
one of the the the Gracie break down
there sure go replay like what happened
in this critter you know and they're
like you don't watch out for this you
think it's one guy being an [ __ ] but
you meanwhile he's got three friends
behind him that you don't know and makes
you think about stuff see that one like
Nate Diaz when he was 19 like wrestled
some guy and it like slapping was okay
and but they're just like in the gym and
he beat some like God it was like twenty
eight or something like that he looks so
young in it oh I think he has blonde
hair yeah uh-huh
he looks like he's 13 yep Nate what were
we just talking about Sam that you're
saying yep - oh yeah an 80s he's a good
guy boxing I'm bigging slap are we
having an event for Nate Diaz his next
fight because when is it look at this
guy just coming at him flat boxing yeah
look how young is I think he's at 19 in
this thing yeah yeah yeah who is he
fighting against that Dustin Poirier oh
poor yeah yeah that's right
I thought he's fighting his dad right
here like this is his Uncle Bob who got
into his weed stash what that guy's
thinking right there the guy in the
mid-180s are the only ones who went
through our blonde hair face did anyone
else have everyone yeah that's why you
ever do that Jason do you ever ever
you're blond tips face my brother did is
I mean I had blond hair brother has
blond hair right now it is like it's
like long and kurt cobain kind of
looking like blonde yeah he bleached it
himself so it doesn't look that great
come BAM wrap me boink being a redhead
like that was like my identity for the
longest time I was like even though they
made fun of me I was like you know what
that's cool though I'm a redhead and
then as time goes by and you start
losing your hair you're like when did
you start losing your I don't even
recall you ever having here in the 20
years I've known you
oh that's cool
[Laughter]
was big thick ya know for so long that
you forget yeah II know I started
getting you I was trying to like dude I
used to have like crazy bright red hair
and then it was thick and then I started
I went for the short haircut that was my
maneuver I'll say you know I'll go for
this or haircut that way people will
notice as much I guess it worked but
then and then I would like trying to
spike it up a little bit Rogaine but
then you got to be consistent with it
twice a day and it smelled weird so I
would do it like once every couple
months and then actually had this bald
brother-in-law and whenever I'd see him
I'd be like oh [ __ ] I need to put that
Rogaine in so I look like him and then
and then eventually I was just like I
think about a year and a half ago I said
I'm just gonna shave it and I I never
used the blade in the shaving cream I
just go with the razor blade or the you
know the electric razor I thought you
use a knife that's not saying a tiara
you have the kind of haircut it looks
like you could cut it with a spoon but
if you guys if you're out if you're
going bald you know I'm sure there's
some things to do but if you just want
to shave it it's the best move it's the
best good that'd be Michael Jordan's
greatest contribution to mankind is
making Paul's cool yeah like they say
that like men Fitness Magazine vase they
can statistically show that they sell
more magazines when a bald guys on the
cover compared to an apple yeah under
water looks better when you guys just
save it though yeah don't be balding you
know like you don't want to have like
cult a second look or that Friar Tuck
look or that horse shoes yeah we watched
Rogan struggle with that for a long time
you know I mean like he fought his
baldness forever and now that he's just
bald it looks great I think it's I think
it shocked people at first right like
like when I first you know shave the
head like I got four compliments right
away now granted they were from other
bald man welcome to the club yes but
then my wife at first was like oh why
did you do that but then now she's like
and then I saw her old picture she's
like yeah yeah you did the best that was
about it say that's yeah
let me ask you something um I meant do
you are you do you think bald men are
attractive and I really think it's much
better when they like let it go if like
you're balding doesn't I don't know what
you looked like before so I don't know
well listen I had it's so funny now I
get you my wife cuz she's like even when
you had hair Darren you didn't know what
to do with it so I it was bright red
come on I offense any bright red heads
out there but I actually find women now
with shaved heads hot I didn't like it
at first but now I do anything normal
I'd be like you're into that look at
their Larry David yeah this this hot
bartenders [ __ ] armpits all weekend
up in Canada I saw you do that at
Sycamore tavern you were like oh she's
Herbie Oh smells so great don't judge me
I'm not judging I'm saying I've seen you
do what you're saying you like talker
and you better tip her for letting you
hurt ya so that's that man Jason what do
you like shaved head long here on big
Bush girls yeah yeah I like big Bush on
top of her head bald [ __ ] [ __ ] hair on
the head mustache and I like a nice big
[ __ ] with balls underneath it how about
you guys don't judge me bro oh just me
it happens dude
sometimes you like it's I beggars can't
be choosers I just you know anybody
that'll talk to me I feel like I'm in as
a man once you get into your 40s you're
just beggars can't be choosers boy right
you're just like you're the Invisible
Man
there's just no matter what you do
you're just the funny man you might get
into your 50s and then be like damn I
was not invisible now I am it or 60s or
70s and me like you don't I mean it's
funny like whenever you look back at
your life like ten years before you're
like what I was like complaining about
yeah yeah yeah 100% yeah I mean you're
just yeah every time I go mom and go
notes she's like Majan being my age I'm
like okay that's good
yeah cuz I see now it's when you get
older like you know I'm in my late 40s
and I'm 49 and I'll see a comedian you
know and they're like 36 or 37 talking
about being old and like like I have a
hard time looking for the remote and I'm
like dude you're so young stuff yes I
break it down for him I go okay 35 now
you start feeling the hangovers now you
start like it definitely slows down 40
is a giant change in your body like
rigor mortis starts setting in and you
got to keep moving and you just I would
saying maybe I just seen this on this
show but this is not even a joke even
though it's hilarious I blew a hamstring
out taking a nap whoa I woke up from a
nap and I couldn't straighten my [ __ ]
left leg out like it hurt for like a
week this is why you should go with some
RAM socks yeah put my RAM socks on
doctors say I hit the message you got
slowed down you know I'll prescribe some
Ram sock Oh get some socks on those are
good for your legs and circulation it
the mountains you'll be through booking
booking bro this has to infuriate you no
it does it really doesn't you stick to
your point yeah he's not a game changer
and the Raiders are better without
Khalil Mac dude we had him last year we
didn't do anything okay
I love Khalil Mac he's one of my
favorite players but it's just like I
don't want to pay that much money to a
guy that I isn't going to like I would
rather spend it on just teepees that's
my whole thing DPS but what do I know
I'm a piece of [ __ ]
I tell you who's awesome on the Raiders
is [ __ ] beast mode beast it takes 15
people to tackle that guy Amari any
Cooper's playing better too he used to
drop all the balls he's actually
catching them this time yeah I don't
think he he doesn't strike fear in
anybody to me Cooper how [ __ ] white
boy working out what's the name
they're all good dude the offense isn't
the problem
it's just like we get tired and such and
half because we didn't know there was a
second half we're totes only if we're
only gonna play this long and then
everyone's like let's let's run it again
we're like we're not really into that so
like as I said we are first half champs
your first half Super Bowl champs right
you guys won the first half of the Super
Bowl you got to start looking at
football no smile dude I love that
picture zekiel Eliot what is what is
going on the Ewok you walk look at them
it's good down back though they pull him
up and like compare him like just put in
Ezekiel Elliott he walk oh when I say
this guy that looks exactly like this
Ewok look at this doesn't he wow that
other one the one words on the bottom
there wow that yeah look at that
oh come on man that's not even race
that's that's the fun kind of racism if
you were like oh that's racism like not
really I didn't say anything racist
about that but yeah it looks like a
goddamn Ewok the eyes the [ __ ] that's
a hilarious photo it must just be
getting that's good too is he so what
the chick they pulled out her chi Chi's
like cuz that chicks a ride-or-die [ __ ]
right oh no that was just like that
wasn't his chick whoever those hot girls
that's a girl I'd hang out with on my
back [ __ ] is ride or die what happened
I don't know he was that like I look
like a Mardi Gras kind of party and he
was on up like a patio like there's like
a lot of people on the street there's
like a bunch of people on this patio and
there was a girl like celebrating and he
just like pulled her shirt done pulled
her know one of her tits out or whatever
and everybody went crazy about it yeah
that's right here she's like you want
this you want this give me some beads
yeah that's exactly right that's it
that's all to happen every butt
crazy did he get in trouble for that
yeah a little bit Oh big time she covers
herself so it's like they can say she's
didn't want it well it's just that in
this day and age it's and it's
unfortunate that and I don't you can't
grab a girl by the tits anymore or push
her off a balcony and you know what I
think it's not cool where's this guy
going Dallas Cowboy fan breaks handcuffs
escapes police yeah where does he think
he's going and I was pretending like
he's still in handcuffs
yeah how'd he do it he just twisted it
yeah he knew what he was doing
and isn't that a typical cowboy fan one
to even just be like put it back
together so he doesn't get in trouble
he's like Oh beat up the cops something
come in oh I don't know that just to me
that's just a typical cowboy fan typical
like smart like that oh yeah then he
gets out of this oh that's great and
they plan this they say maybe guys might
try to climb out of the ceiling and then
he's got the [ __ ] car his ankles are
locked so we're gonna go it's like dude
I'm just in the weird [ __ ] dude this
room's more secure there's no there's no
ceiling to break out of if we had to
break out of here but we do well first
we kill Aaron I'd go sit one of those
windows oh those aren't windows those
are sound protector foam things is jason
witten on Monday night Foucault the
whole mundane echoes I guess yeah he's
uh it's unlistenable how did they not
know he was gonna [ __ ] the bed
how did not listening to do not go oh
dude that guy's not good Romo's good
Romo was great yeah bro Mo's good James
John Whetton what's his name is the
Horeb fisherman jason witten is horrible
he's horrible yeah a lot of people have
been complaining about the money night
crew I saw Tiana was tweeting about how
unlistenable they all are it's like yeah
dude he's dude like awesome stuff that's
really good she's my special Jagger
trick was made absolutely no sense yeah
you're asking these guys to be genetic
athlete super freaks on top of that
being comics and [ __ ] Varian it just
need only get 1 out of 10 you only you
know maybe like Barclays fun you know
but I mean just because you're an axe
player and a star doesn't mean you
should be doing commentary or
play-by-play or you know and gone are
the days of the [ __ ] like you and I like
like the Harry Caray's and the people
that have just been there forever just
some crazy [ __ ] old dude that just
loves that one team that's gone yeah
well it's gonna be hot people and famous
people that's it which is so weird for
comedy I mean for sports because men if
you get paralyzed one job that an ugly
person can do and do well and if you put
in your time men men love people who've
earned it and worked their time they
love to watch a guy who's come in day in
day out and will and [ __ ] put in the
time and the effort to achieve something
it's not like the e-channel where they
can't get a new younger they would put
fetuses in there if they [ __ ] could
go to the days of the Bob Uecker and
they're like a funny [ __ ]
old guy that's like has stories for days
I love those guys those guys don't yeah
they dare to just go the Dodgers
broadcast is [ __ ] suck I love Orel
Hershiser he's [ __ ] awful and the new
guy they got no stories and it's sadness
some real classic example it's just like
I love that and sports so weird because
even though for every fight nany you
have the watches like an MMA fight
there's like a thousand men watching it
and it's just like as much as we're like
women love sports it's not nearly to the
level that men do and men don't meet
shiny new objects men love guys who put
in time and have great stories to tell
back in 65 yeah stuff like that I love
first time I hung out with it Negro and
we just define myself and it was like
okay I appreciate that [ __ ] a story like
this remember like Howard Cosell yeah of
the classics the new dude is the new guy
on the diamond good go all the way isn't
bad he's just not entertaining he can
talk he's not a karakia the monday night
cruise is garbage and again who do we
had to blame for that our least favorite
Network I'm telling you dude
yes you know let's see is it a word
[ __ ] trouble they took the cash and
they're dancing with the devil what they
NFL what's going on with the NFL right
now in ESPN just pounding the NFL like
almost like just the [ __ ] roon it
they're gonna do that with the UFC
they're gonna [ __ ] dude these guys smack
chicks around these guys are all
cheating on peds they're gonna [ __ ]
destroy them on all that [ __ ] the
wife-beating [ __ ] there's no place for
that but [ __ ] okay you're open-minded
Never Say Never
okay Never Say Never but I'm not saying
every wife deserves a good smacking
around but it's true it lose a good
shakin so that's my point it's just like
it's just the ESPN is the worst I don't
want to sound sexist I know I really
don't but if we can't beat smacking
these [ __ ] around anymore maybe we
got to give these [ __ ] are real good
shakin okay your thoughts Manny speaking
of racism I was thinking about this the
other day I knew this guy I went to
college in the middle of Indiana and I
grew up in the northern part of the
state where like by Gary and Haman like
where there's a lot of african-american
people in the southern part of the state
not so much there was this guy named
Lonnie Belleville who I had like a day
job I was like printing t-shirts when
this guy was there we're about 20 and
we're just talking while you're working
you know regular [ __ ] and he wasn't
racist guy at all but he grew up in the
than part of the state and he actually
said this is a true story I never saw a
real live black person until I wrestled
one in high school Wow
so not only is this guy like never other
than television and movies and whatnot
never been face to face with in an
african-american person at all the first
time he sees one
he now has to try to pin him isn't that
crazy that is crazy [ __ ] that must been
going on in his head like man you just
melt like a regular person do you
remember a female comic named Amy
Snowden like it just blew all I remember
her you have yeah she's great man just
another she's a wonderful person yeah
ever happen it happened but uh she's
like man I didn't think Jews are real
people I mean I read a mind the Bible
but I thought they were like hobbits and
[ __ ] you know yeah that's hilarious
she's white and her name it has the word
snow in it yeah all right Snowden she's
actually won a very nice one super nose
yeah yeah I haven't seen her forever
totally forgot about that
that was a good impression of her
actually know her or laughing yeah her
guitar like two strings on it yeah yeah
yeah she's great
um the close eyes of that story is I
never saw a [ __ ] before I saw the
safety dance video wow really yeah you
didn't even know like that would be a
thing to dance laughter by the way what
you're not I went to an 80s concert at
the Greek Theatre last year yeah they
were on them oh really
they were yeah they were they were great
men without hats you they actually are
still play they are I'll tell you a
funny story about I'll go see so in the
heart of the the first guy Africans
named Paul something very slow song the
sun's still out oh and then you know I'm
walking on sunshine she came out and
then the third act was I'll stop the
world and melt with you I'll stop the
world in my modern English and the guy
was like and right then it was starting
to be good
little bit darker and you know there
weren't all white and they got their
keytars and it's funny because it's not
metallic avatars never took off and yeah
totally [ __ ] and it's a total 80s
concert he goes because how is everyone
feeling and the crowd kind of goes yeah
and then how about showing some [ __ ]
enthusiasm and the crowd gets a little
bit louder I think they got away yeah
and then they go into their music I'll
stop the world didn't do that once all
else okay I was just gonna say real
quick st. and then they came out they
were awesome because they're men without
hats they don't make you wait for it
they don't don't know [ __ ] he walks
up to the microphone he goes you can
dance if you want to you can leave your
friends behind and if your friends don't
dance and if they don't dance whether no
friends are mine I love that [ __ ]
that is the first song I love it's so
good and they're like this speaks to me
I don't need them and I'll leave them
behind they did about four or five songs
Damon the dogs probably dead now
never never never great song in it
something about whatever another great
song in there and then and then them and
then they end on safety dance they do
the longer version oh they did it yeah
I'll put up with it in the close one
more time [ __ ] yeah cuz they don't do it
exactly like the first when they first I
love it when you can dance if you want
to you can leave your phone and then
when they close with it they go remember
that the version when they spell it out
you know the thing about midgets is no
one is exactly alike yeah you know I
mean like human thank you everyone
like snowflakes now regular real people
they're all very similar I remember the
first time I saw a [ __ ] I had to
wrestle it I did I do have a wrestling a
[ __ ] story really is it hard it was as
awesome rock hard do who won um well it
was like wrestle like you guys are on
the wrestling team
but I played basketball in high
when the basketball season would end
wrestling would start and nobody would
was it much into wrestling in my high
school and so the coach would always try
to get like the basketball players or
whatever to come out for wrestling and
he kept bugging me about it because I
was so skinny as a kid okay not that I'm
not a basketball that it would be like
hey did you I was gonna wait class that
he wanted to have you know I mean and
I'm like I don't want to rest on these
like just come out for one Saturday
practice if you don't like I'll never
bug you about doing it again so I did
and there was a you know a little person
in my high school who was on the
wrestling team but because my weight
class was closest to the midgets that's
who I had to practice against so what a
way to sell me on going up for wrestling
cuz I'm like [ __ ] I don't even want to
[ __ ] be here but now I got a fight
and now I gotta find a [ __ ] on top of
it yeah yeah and he probably knew some
moves that course he the team he knows
all those [ __ ] moves with his hot dog
fingers wrapping around me instead look
out dude every [ __ ] I know it's famous
they're also yeah three they're doing
wrestling or porn you know oh you seen
this one weird like this black [ __ ]
just bangs his white chicken she's like
I've made bad decisions they always had
that weird arm where it's like it's
going and then it [ __ ] and then it
just look like the guy right there like
see how weird the arm is it's like it's
it's weird it's gotta be held you know
like a like on st. Patty's Day or
something they probably just avoid like
nightclubs and bars they're like it's
amateur hour like yeah about [ __ ] new
oh dude Asian [ __ ] you don't see that
a lot you know yeah couple Mexicans some
white ones but never Asian [ __ ] I just
our Asian midgets just like three inches
shorter than regular Asians look at this
guy he could dance if he wants to
believe his friends Bayesian oh yeah man
he pain that guy's a [ __ ] pedophile
he's banging that hot [ __ ] down there
look at that guy right down oh yeah yeah
yeah right there look at that he's just
knocking the bottom out of that
look at that hot stripper [ __ ] nope
nobody's with me on that one there's a
show on like we or oxygen or something
it's like a bunch of little women yeah
and they're like crazy it's like bad
girls club but little women and they all
fight I love the one where that's all
that's all a woman's [ __ ] reality
television yeah just make bad decisions
what if you want to see it in [ __ ]
form you can I like I like what is
Esther ku doing on here I like I like
the one where they help dogs that's not
a [ __ ] that's just a short person
she's not really a [ __ ] she's just
short that's a [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] that likes black
guys yeah who's with me dude we're all
where my [ __ ] what take a call yeah
let's take some calls
hey guys baseball is cool baseball is
cool dude did you guys see when the
Dodgers just ran a train on the
Cardinals it was so great dude so you're
gonna you guys are definitely making the
postseason
I mean we're not definitely doing I
can't believe Darren just walked out you
just quit the show hates baseball Ewan
hates baseball I do the Dodgers are
great the problem is mentally we are
shitty Bob because of our manager will
score 15 runs one game and then the next
game will score no runs and it happens
all the time
and then we'll beat the teams that we're
spoke will destroy annihilate the teams
that we're supposed to struggle against
like the Cardinals like we were in their
guts our dick was deep in their guts we
still won the season series yeah
whatever
43 high you're on with low punch-drunk
sports how are you hey fam okay you
doing this is already getting some weird
how are you ma'am I'm calling I'm
calling to apologize to you fan I
been in a cool down for a while and
actions and and I realized I was being a
smartass and just trying to come off as
being on your side and I'd like for you
to unblock me on Twitter Sam what's your
uggs what's your Twitter handle C
underscore Ranallo alright are you I you
know LAF I'll try to figure it out are
you gonna be cool yeah man I will defend
your honor everywhere I go how did you
get into a cold I'm what is it do you
did it well after the whole hot dog
scenario I tweeted that I would like to
help make sure that re doesn't back out
on the BET and I know Sam's gonna pull
through and do it and better than me
being a smartass I told anybody they
tweet about hot dogs you're getting
black still I got comment about the hi
you've been practicing plunger [ __ ]
my [ __ ] and now you're ready I am
going to if you could email me and with
your Twitter handle I will unblock you
as long as you know that it just be cool
and we're cool is that cool yeah just
tweet me just tweet me just he can't get
I mean I said email me is your email
public knowledge you know okay to say
something real quick
October 23rd re is announced that the
hot dog thing is gonna be paid off I am
telling you this right now not the hash
old [ __ ] I will do it on the 23rd but I
every bet that is older than that better
be paid off Jason you know do your bets
of course not
I like to this is getting more fun to
just fire it up I'll never ever ever pay
off any bet ever and I'm gonna make as
many bets as I can agree
so the bets need to be paid off by that
moment or else's you know I'm just not
gonna do the hot dog which I'm willing
to do now and still people three other
[ __ ] bats or two other bats or three
other bats it's just not fair it's not
fair but I will do it if the bets are
paid off
interesting Darrin you missed it we are
we took alcohol then game everybody
million dollars each billionaire
damn it it was a little person that
called I'm gonna hold my pee in man I
just got to the point where I go yeah
any more calls we're taking calls right
now answering your thing so baseball
okay
real quick what do you want to talk
about Oh talk about the playoffs are
coming up man holy [ __ ] okay what do you
what do you think what's your take
hi you're on with punch-up we're talking
baseball hey Triple E I'm also a lot of
cool down okay I saw this coming
okay I'm just kidding I'm not gonna cool
down I'm a big fan
thank you a major question what are you
guys are doing for all things comedy
fest cuz I have some strippers coming
into town and I'm trying to see if I
should bail on that or go out wait to
all things tell me first why can't you
do both why why do you got to not bring
your about to being a cool down if
you're bringing [ __ ] strippers and
you're not bringing to the show that's
actually good question probably because
I made it up
understand what kind of relationship do
you have like with it like ya got four
strippers coming to hang out that's a
really weird way to ask what we're doing
this will make me sound really cool
that's called clickbait it's almost porn
watch it yeah hey Mad Love your profile
want to see my naked
oh I wanna see your naked pics I miss
porn BOTS Twitter really ruined
themselves when they got rid of porn but
what is going on is this calll Appaloosa
hello you're on with off hey yeah
stop riding a horse for a second right
what do you hang up on this guy
indicators on a horse in a wind tunnel
next up hi you're on with puncturing
sports you're on with Jason Kiba I was
so Jason Sam I was talking about Jason
who would you rather face the in the
first round of playoffs the Cardinals
are the Brewers probably Cardinals I'd
love you guys probably we just worked
Milwaukee that we just worked Milwaukee
which made me feel a little bit more
confident about that because they were
on our heels I think that uh the the
Cubs and the Dodgers are on a collision
course I told you that last night I
think that's gonna be the NL
championship I think so yep Cubs Dodgers
okay you're out you're in the chill out
your cool down uh what'd you do to get
in there I think it was pizza gate okay
hey peeps again oh hi all right yeah I
just want to let you know Sam I still
love you Oh Don Carlos Don I love you to
death you're one of my favorite people
okay you I love you too dad you just run
a joke into the ground
it was just like the fifth or sixth time
I was over at Ryan okay I love you the
day hey Ryan staring Carter what's up
man you know he's the party starter I
know everybody you guys are awesome but
I mean I guess I'm still gonna be in the
chill-out zone oh you don't need to be
in the chill-out zone if you don't want
to just stop running okay hung up on us
okay that's a real call right now yeah
good food good yeah go to go to Don
Carlos if you're in in a San Diego La
Jolla area but don't talk about pizza
gay cuz I'll put you in the highway to
[ __ ] it if you go to Don Carlos and you
you say hashtag
false-flag you get something free hey
well so much for [ __ ] baseball talk
we're gonna shut that down go back to
the standings Johnny Johnny go back to
standings why play the punch on guys
didn't hold up there at there and I play
what here what did we not hold up Daryl
heard what did we not hold up fantasy
football what we not hold up I don't
know
oh we're gonna be looking for a new
shirt guy - yeah blow that up for my
blind ass dude there's a place for $80
you know glasses and I exam two
turntables that you email me yeah
somebody some guy glasses were stolen
from my car and I'm like that's a weird
thing to steal because they can't even
use them dude I've had people steal my
radio and cap my wires for me just to be
like so you don't care shock - hey man
like that's a nice you're not worried
about the Rockies you don't know dude
we've been destroying those unsuspecting
fools hi you're armed with punch-drunk
sports you're on with the fight nany how
are you eight one two are you alive
eight one two god they hung up on the
fight name you're on a cool-down yeah
cool [ __ ] cool down how many games
are left twelve yeah twelve yeah yeah
you're welcome
why do you guys for the pumps anyway
there's less for other teams yeah
comes in some makeups yeah because it
was like the whole first month of a
snowing during baseball in Chicago they
use their off day to fly to Washington
to play one game and I think that'll
catch up to to the Cubs having to jam
all these games in late
yeah I'm killing it today if you don't
I'm on fire you have to win your
division to get making it into the post
right now we're tied with st. Louis for
their [ __ ] wildcards we don't got do
jack [ __ ] no you know you're leading the
division
yeah we're leading the division and
we're a half game up by a half a game
dude [ __ ] your last week you were saying
the Dodgers was out what happened in I
didn't say last week that was you and
they were then they beat us no you and
Dana were both devastated last week Dana
was talking to me you wanna quit life so
what happened so much fun I love it
don't get I go you go girl
yeah gaga the closest team to the
Dodgers was the Cardinals and then the
Dodgers won three of four so they made
up a bunch of ground right okay thank
you but they're still it's half a game
and they have to win their division to
make the postseason what if they won
only the first half well if I correct me
if I'm wrong but right now our last
series our it really dude it goes we're
finishing up with the the Colorado
Rockies all those are winnable yeah
winnable if not we can go undefeated in
that in that stretch because all those
teams the Arizona Arizona's almost out
they're like they're almost done it is a
snuff film what's going on with their
game today and tomorrow those games are
huge because you're only up half a game
Oh in Colorado yeah we've been [ __ ]
in their guts dude I mean we are just so
deep and they're like God we're like
we're [ __ ] shish-kebab and they're
[ __ ] lunch that's how deep in their
guts they're what well cuz you can't
pitch in it just pitch in Colorado all
right keep saying that [ __ ] keep
saying that [ __ ] what you can't look
at st. Louis has a 60 66.5 which is more
like 666 because there's a [ __ ] devil
right
guys we're gonna take another call hi
you're on with Darren Carter the party
starter hello hello yeah can we get a
bag of bets versa
Sam verse the Johnny Braves man the
Braves in the first round
dude there's so many bag of bats at home
that I would love to do a bag of bats
I'd love to deal bag of bats but there's
so many with Johnny hasn't done one well
Johnny's afraid to do that
Johnny's a hot dog bet they let him out
you you dropped out of the hot dog pen
oh she just called you out home because
it was when he said you you [ __ ]
chicken down the hot dog bat I know you
begged for it
you were crying on the phone about how
your bum bum is afraid of hot dogs you
know he would have won the whole thing
is all of you would have you hot dogs
yeah yeah yeah T benefited the most
lucky team hey dude so there's gonna be
no bets cuz [ __ ] dude ah Johnny knows
the Braves are gonna get a [ __ ]
everybody's gettin Dodger trains deep
down this is gonna really blow up in
your face if they don't make the
postseason everybody and Twitter is
gonna be on a cool-down for talking
about Whoopie Sam versus everyone just
[Laughter]
it'll just be Sam reading his own tweets
it is like the lowly kid that has all
the toys just sitting in the playground
that no one wants to play with oh by the
way bet deicide luck oh no I wanna see
the schedule this week I made bet yes I
loves me and everybody on Twitter hates
me because my lock of the week this week
lost you know how many tweets I got I
didn't put anybody on cooldown I just
apologized like a man I know let's see
jets Browns I wouldn't touch that Saints
[ __ ] I definitely wouldn't touch that
Niners Chiefs oh I think the Chiefs p29
is that might be the lock of the week
let's see what else we got
Raiders dolphins I mean Raiders were in
the first half of that bills Vikings
bills are bad dude bills Vikings the
bills are bad that's my lock of the week
might be mine - sam Tripoli's lock of
the week
Vikings over bills everybody's pissed
because I'm saying the bills might move
to Toronto Buffalo's freaking the [ __ ]
out broncos Ravens yeah probably
there probably is Vikings over taxons
but the Giants just look like garbage
the other night there Dallas is garbage
and Dallas have just handed it to him
Chargers Ramsey they had a battle for
Los Angeles chargers RAM charges are
good - were they playing is there gonna
be anybody in that stadium by the way
it's a Coliseum no it's at the Coliseum
I'm gonna go with Cardinals there's our
one in one now go here beers are what go
cards [ __ ] the Cardinals I'll never root
for them even in [ __ ] football
Seahawks
oh and to see OTT suck Patriots Lions by
the lines look like Shih Tzu like dog
[ __ ] sevens a lotto boss look good dude
do you think they trade Jameis Winston I
think that they should who would be good
who's got a shitty quarterback that they
could you the Raiders um a shitty
quarterback I mean the bills no Josh
Collins their future they just have no
line I mean Tannehill no blackout um
Tyra and rothsburgher I mean Jax
Jacksonville maybe portals I mean not
they're not definitely not the Chiefs
Ritz gotta be somewhere where the
somebody's old like Eli
that could it could could they go get
them and uh could they make a trade for
Jameis Winston to the Giants I don't see
anybody that yeah maybe but they got
Josh Rosen he's their future we got a
call from the 603 it's probably Jameis
Winston hey turn your radio down I love
saying hello you're on live you're
online would Jason Tebow fight nany and
Darren Carter the party starter I'm
saying that Jameis Winston to the Bears
mr. busy garbage Oh thoughts Jason
they'd I don't see that happening Ike I
mean he's got a lot to earn it's so
interesting that a guy that played 14
college games has now played but [ __ ]
about as many pro games he only played
14 college games right Johnny Johnny was
told how great he was he's like always
gonna kill it and I'm like the only
thing good about to Brisky is his mom
I'd bang her hard hard hard we see
another thing of his mom real quick
he gets a shot this important yes
look how hot his mom is dude boom let me
hit that
BAM hot mom Jesus Christ what is wrong
with you
hey next week we have the caliente
combat people on the some of the dancers
will be coming down and telling us why
and by the way real quick you guys your
love this dude you are gonna [ __ ]
love this yeah you're gonna [ __ ] love
this let me okay so great audio so far
well uh Caliente Cage Rage that's right
the 27 they are giving us special seats
at their fight downtown at the I believe
it's Dame's and games fight flow yeah so
next layers yeah they're gonna be coming
on boom we're gonna be in fights I'm so
excited to be a part of this
I'm so excited it doesn't look like your
thing Casey do you not want to go I'll
decide I'll decide hello hi you're on
with us what's up
great no it's not the same dude it's a
different dude Bruce in the same area
code okay interesting what is the other
one oh yeah what city are you in I want
to ask trip I want to ask Tripoli was he
like
if he friends with Jon Gruden did he
like make some skirt or like trade for
Khalil max cuz like I don't what
happened he's a really good player for
the Bears I don't know what happened but
he's hands-down the best player on the
burial I feel like I'm talking to mr.
Beane right now this accent um I'm gonna
go with that the defense wasn't strong
with Coolio Mac they want and they made
a tray okay I just like didn't go into
it that is it the Raiders defense wasn't
strong with Kobe only yes or is he just
a clever player that he brought he was
just pissed off that the Raiders they
want to re-sign him and he just like
talking i'ma bring the Bears defense to
this whole new level
ah no it was that he wanted to get paid
more and I get that your football player
got short window you want to get paid
and the Raiders didn't want pay him now
the question is could they pay him I
don't know but they didn't want to pay
they didn't want to pay him [ __ ] 25
mil a year and hey [ __ ] Chicago's got
a low had a low salary cap and Headroom
in it and now they got a win we'll see
how the we won't know to the end it the
if the if the Bears make the playoffs
and they're good that's a good trade
that's my opinion we got we got to first
we'll take it I like it I like it I like
it a lot
I'd rather spend that money personally
on D doing I couldn't tell by your
questioning question I'm Colin
Kaepernick should definitely be as a the
Bears quarterback luck this Mitchell
true Biscay character he's the what I
would love to see a capital W Kaepernick
to the Bears would make me extremely
happy just let me say this to you dude
Kaepernick
doesn't want to play okay he's making
he's like the Susan Lucci of the NFL men
want Susan Lucci went 18 years getting
nominated and everybody was talking
about her now she won nobody talks about
her you don't think she'd give that Emmy
back in a heartbeat just to have people
still talking about
can't [ __ ] win it's the same thing
with Kaepernick dude he's making more
money not playing than he would be
playing and then let's talk about the a
Greek guy who did the same thing that
Kaepernick did and he can't get work and
he's not getting any Nike [ __ ] deal
for 30 mil listen dude you have to write
to me all you have to write the protest
but dude it's just like good look at
Chris Hardwick right Chris Hardwick gets
[ __ ] losers all of us all this
[ __ ] work at what all this shows at
one point right nobody in the comedy
community will come out and say anything
for him because he didn't want to get
political or in trouble right cuz it's a
corporate gig riding on show being on
all corporate gigs it's the same thing
with football it's a corporate [ __ ]
gig he has the right to protest all he
wants to he got offered to be traded to
Denver and they were gonna sign him at
[ __ ] Baltimore until his girlfriend
put out that root that [ __ ] tweet
about [ __ ] Django Unchained okay so
like it's like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] him
and the clicky claims whoo Kaepernick
[ __ ] all of them 405 you're on damn how
are you I'm doing good pretty good
rushing what city is 405 City Oklahoma
City yeah are you worried about
Russell Westbrook getting surgery so
close to the season like this we can you
know get into working summer I'm
thinking that's probably what there was
I think that OKC should figure out a way
to trade for Blake Griffin that's my
opinion maybe maybe I don't know see
that gonna be a breakout year for him I
mean maybe but Blake Griffin is too
legit top 20 talent when he's focused
and he does that he's on that team he
doesn't have to carry the team Blake
Griffin get you three okay guy the bills
guy oh he started to yeah yeah we are
thoughts on that Jason I thought it was
awesome I think just happened yet Sunday
halftime 20 years ago that
reminiscing about no no Sunday that the
bills are losing this guy takes his
jersey off quits the team and retires
from football during halftime he's old
he's been around for a while but he was
just like [ __ ] this I'm done yeah I'm
out and calls an uber and hey could you
turn off the game I don't want to hear
that [ __ ] no guy he's 30 yeah 30 what's
gonna do why do you do that because dude
he knew that that team is fought yeah
they they're purposely [ __ ] the
season up you don't make these bad
decisions like this you just don't both
those brothers are crazy though oh those
are twins Bennet Vernon Davis was always
you think he'll be back crazy Zeke I'll
be back on another team or you think
it's I don't know I don't know when you
quit like that it's some people might
not want I said it was kind of rude I've
never read anything that is rude look at
our team look at that the Bills fan
right here he's a wonderful dude he's
like bills aren't leaving well he get
his money I think it was uh I think it
was done it's shitty with that bat that
play-by-play team the booth sucks it's
once again the [ __ ] suits not knowing
what the [ __ ] they're doing that Bears
defense is fun to watch it's fun like
you can literally just watch number 52
doesn't make you on the whole play
Cleo Mackey you can I was literally just
watching how much havoc he wreaks oh
yeah that's right I would say I will go
with Minnesota the spread is 17 holy
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that's spread I didn't know
the spread was that that's a lot
and what's Kansas City spread all right
you got Kansas City over San Francisco
six and a half I'll take that then
you ready from my cold heart Kansas City
and ready City Oakland Raiders over
Miami in neighbours hat take the first
half points first half take first half
don't shout on the second
half just go first half course you can
that's my lock of the week high five -
oh you're on with Jason
Darren fight nanny and the [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey Ron hey yeah what's
going on guys what's up what's happening
just calling to see if you guys any
extra fantasy football like sleepers
anybody who's gonna do well I thought
that he'd miss you guys like for the
first two weeks I'll be a sauce Gordon
Josh Gordon if that guy can you know
keep his dick in the game
himmat the Patriots just is terrifying
Tom Brady thrown a Josh Gordon is
terrifying that's the last place I
wanted him to go do I think this is
gonna get anybody this year I don't know
it's we're getting later in the season
you think he would be on a team by now I
don't think so I think he doesn't play
this year for a while I thought he would
you know you're always one injury away
from somebody you know working out des
and signing him somebody big gets hurt
you know he's on a lot of people's like
his name is on a lot of desks right now
like I'll maybe if we need to turn that
off what is that
turn off that ad I don't want to do nad
for five hours they don't want have
Dukan so talk to FanDuel see they can
get on this what was the one that that
fired us remember I mean that was the
funny it was the funnier email that we
got that email I don't know there's no
way he would have it oh it's so [ __ ]
what was it when your sponsors yeah well
we had a sponsor and we enjoyed while he
eats the product when he walks home and
we were talking about it was really
funny but though by the way he's cause
once I've caused - so I'm definitely the
worst at this so how does it work you
guys go look start we've got a sponsor
then and then like the rules will be
read
just do the read don't [ __ ] with it
don't improvise then occasionally we
forget we just go off and we basically
did the job he has to eat this thing to
drown out all the dick sucking in [ __ ]
they did not appreciate that I wasn't
here on that one it was all me but I'd
and then we got an email outside that
like makes it a bad project it's like so
he's walking eating and it's like he
can't help that happens it's just
we just they this some of these people
it's time that anyone got offended they
got they got worried that someone might
get offended and that's most political
crack yeah if you actually look no one's
actually bitching it's like someone
could get upset about this you're like
and then everybody just runs with it but
people have to eat the dick sucking is
still here the crunchy
why do I go with soft shell sure one
with hard show dick sucking or eating
the hard shows the hardshell tacos such
a good show we crushed any other calls
all right well just seems like uh yeah
how about this how about we call it a
day how are you doing in economy start
financially I am one in one I'm too and
all are you upset that you're doing
worse than Cleveland [ __ ]
no I'm undefeated in the Comedy Store
one oh you are yeah you're good and I'm
2 and O 1 and 1 and O & 2 I'm a 1 & 1 &
2 now hi you're on with puncturing
sports we're talking WNBA fantasy league
I got a few points on now but first of
all I got a beef with all things comedy
festival webpage has all sorts of
mentioned and Brendan Schaub zero
mention of punch-drunk oh that seems to
be a feel seemlessly dream seems to be a
thing
on the website a lot of people that
aren't all things comedy that are being
promoted yeah welcome Brenton
welcome to it's a business [ __ ] I run
the website one oh but the Instagram is
like come see Adam Carolla what does he
have to do with this yeah welcome to
business even though we I mean it
listen Aaron you tell me who had the
best podcast at the festival last year
who put the festival on the [ __ ] map
huh he wants to know what day I'll take
it that's a good he doesn't even know
what dated sports I strung can the best
podcast of the festival free and you did
not have to buy tickets for oh yeah so
there you go you know yeah we're tickets
to see we don't know what you're doing
mom so the chairs were putting on the
street yeah yeah an ATC doesn't book the
stand-up shows guys breaking news I'm at
the belly room Saturday night at 8 p.m.
breaking news guys so thank you for that
call I didn't write it
Saturday Friday and Saturday they'll be
stand-up shows you can buy tickets for
that we will all be at makes it stamina
and we're gonna do a live punch drunk we
don't know what date or time yet that
depends on you know we know he's gonna
be around but you can also come to that
which will probably be free I responded
to my email already yeah me too you guys
are Friday Saturday yeah you know I
think this guy brought up a gabon I mean
sorry I got a most hotel those two days
yeah yeah I mean dude our podcasts just
blew off the internet blowing up the
right we had a gun man with a young
youth doing anti-semitic jokes okay we
have snatchy snap pops on re and then
Doug Stanhope came in and pissed on
everybody and by everyone I mean re
okay hmm what more do we gotta do to get
respect
stop yelling buta start okay would be a
start
well Darren you came in and you rocked
Thank You Man go have me and like I said
if people want to check out my podcast
it's called pocket party a search darren
carter pocket party my youtube channel
is awesome thanks to your help Sam
Tripoli no problem I used to jerk off
through my pants and I called that my
pocket your pocket party yeah guys it's
been a great show on Jason you crushed
today you were on fire I don't know
what's happened to you
fire oh it was a great show and we'll
see you next week next week we have
young ethnic strippers coming in so
enjoy through booking